And if your brain is failing
at integrating bad news about the future,
you will constantly leave your rose-tinted spectacles on.
So we wanted to know, could we change this?
Could we alter people's optimism bias
by interfering with the brain activity in these regions?
And there's a way for us to do that.
This is my collaborator Ryota Kanai.
And what he's doing is he's passing a small magnetic pulse
through the skull of the participant in our study
into their inferior frontal gyrus.
And by doing that,
he's interfering with the activity of this brain region
for about half an hour.
After that everything goes back to normal, I assure you.
(Laughter)
So let's see what happens.
First of all, I'm going to show you
the average amount of bias that we see.
So if I was to test all of you now,
this is the amount that you would learn
more from good news relative to bad news.
Now we interfere with the region
that we found to integrate negative information in this task,
and the optimism bias grew even larger.
We made people more biased in the way that they process information.
Then we interfered with the brain region
that we found to integrate good news in this task,
and the optimism bias disappeared.
We were quite amazed by these results
because we were able to eliminate
a deep-rooted bias in humans.
And at this point we stopped and we asked ourselves,
would we want to shatter the optimism illusion into tiny little bits?
If we could do that, would we want to take people's optimism bias away?
Well I've already told you about all of the benefits of the optimism bias,
which probably makes you want to hold onto it for dear life.
But there are, of course, pitfalls,
and it would be really foolish of us to ignore them.
Take for example this email I recieved
from a firefighter here in California.
He says, "Fatality investigations for firefighters
often include 'We didn't think the fire was going to do that,'
even when all of the available information
was there to make safe decisions."
This captain is going to use our findings on the optimism bias
to try to explain to the firefighters
why they think the way they do,
to make them acutely aware of this very optimistic bias in humans.
So unrealistic optimism can lead to risky behavior,
to financial collapse, to faulty planning.
The British government, for example,
has acknowledged that the optimism bias
can make individuals more likely
to underestimate the costs and durations of projects.
So they have adjusted the 2012 Olympic budget
for the optimism bias.
My friend who's getting married in a few weeks
has done the same for his wedding budget.
And by the way, when I asked him about his own likelihood of divorce,
he said he was quite sure it was zero percent.
So what we would really like to do,
is we would like to protect ourselves from the dangers of optimism,
but at the same time remain hopeful,
benefiting from the many fruits of optimism.
And I believe there's a way for us to do that.
The key here really is knowledge.
We're not born with an innate understanding of our biases.
These have to be identified by scientific investigation.
But the good news is that becoming aware of the optimism bias
does not shatter the illusion.
It's like visual illusions,
in which understanding them does not make them go away.
And this is good because it means
we should be able to strike a balance,
to come up with plans and rules
to protect ourselves from unrealistic optimism,
but at the same time remain hopeful.
I think this cartoon portrays it nicely.
Because if you're one of these pessimistic penguins up there
who just does not believe they can fly,
you certainly never will.
Because to make any kind of progress,
we need to be able to imagine a different reality,
and then we need to believe that that reality is possible.
But if you are an extreme optimistic penguin
who just jumps down blindly hoping for the best,
you might find yourself in a bit of a mess when you hit the ground.
But if you're an optimistic penguin
who believes they can fly,
but then adjusts a parachute to your back
just in case things don't work out exactly as you had planned,
you will soar like an eagle,
even if you're just a penguin.
Thank you.
(Applause)